I am a person who drinks people who
drink need to keep drinking sure you say
that now but after today's episode you
might want to rethink that policy
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where I thought to myself what better
way to celebrate the coming of winter
than by talking about the series where
winter just never seems to quite arrive
one of my favorite shows here on the
channel Game of Thrones up to now we've
concocted theories around Dany John and
Jorah on the last of which I still think
is incredibly likely to happen
but there's one character who was sadly
remained on the sidelines a character
who's been everyone's favorite including
mine since season 1 and by some miracle
has somehow been able to escape the
wheel of death that george RR martin has
hanging on his writing room wall yep
today's theory is about none other than
Tyrion Lannister now in case you're not
familiar with Game of Thrones or this
character in particular while I could
tell you about him I think he sums it up
best a drink and I know things yeah that
about does it and when he says he drinks
man-candy Rhian drink the channel movie
maniacs put together a compilation of
every game of Thrones characters
drinking throughout the first four
seasons and I get a little woozy just
watching it roll the tape
mm-hmm that's a good read more wine
Tyrion hoodie I'm afraid you're drinking
it's really starting to get out of hand
and I don't mean let's get you to
Alcoholics Anonymous I mean more like
your liver is a lump of coal and you
should be cannon on it right now
Tyrion even admit that being a sloshed
as he is at all hours of the day is way
harder than it looks it's not easy being
drunk all the time everyone would do it
if it were easy and it's boasts like
that combined with the seemingly endless
stream of wine going into Tyrians mouth
hole it has me a bit concerned so our
question of the day just how drunk is
Tyrion Lannister what is this guy's
blood-alcohol concentration what kind of
health effect should he be experiencing
but perhaps the most important question
of all in a fantasy series full of
dragons and nice zombies is the most
unbelievable element Tyrians ability to
handle his liquor no I don't think so
see my friend we'll see now don't get me
wrong
Tyrians drinking isn't the kind of
behavior that I'm gonna defend here heck
but most of my friends were in college
out drinking at parties no joke I was
trying to start a show choir yeah talk
about regrettable life decisions and I
was sober suffice it to say that I can't
estimate how drunk Tyrion is from any
kind of personal experience so I'll try
to prove how drunk he is in the best way
that I know how science and some history
and maybe a few leaps of theorist logic
but mostly science so the first thing
that we're gonna need to do if we're
gonna calculate the level of Tyrians
intoxication is determine exactly what
he's drinking game of Thrones Watchers
might know some of these wines by name
like Arbor Gold
Arbor red and Dornish red but what would
the real-world equivalents of these be
it's actually a tricky question since
the popular types and strengths of wine
have changed throughout history and fans
of Game of Thrones argue about when
exactly the series should be set well
the knee-jerk reaction to castles
knights and Dragons would be to put it
into the medieval period which lasted
from the fifth century to the mid 15th
century based on my research Game of
Thrones is actually taking place a bit
later than that sure george RR martin
has said that part of the inspiration
for the series was the English War of
the Roses which took place from 1450
five to 14
seven but there's one piece of evidence
that guarantees the events of the show
are happening at least fifty years after
those dates and for as unimportant as
fifty years might seem that little
difference matters in medieval times
most wine was relatively weak we're
talking somewhere between grape juice
and Mike's Hard Lemonade and that may
sound like a joke but it's not
because by the sixteenth century people
had discovered a new and magical
technology that helped them age wine and
preserve it so it would get stronger
that crucial piece of technology and the
evidence proving the dates that we're
hanging out in Westeros during Game of
Thrones is this yep a cork in season one
the wine merchant who tries to poison
Daenerys pulls a cork out of the cask
and talks about the need to quote let
the wine breathe
so clearly Westeros is hip to the
newfangled cork trend that moment
coupled with their advanced
understanding of medicine large cities
with standing armies and global trading
system points to the series taking place
during the post Columbian Exchange of
the 16th and 17th centuries sorry I just
got a laugh in moments like this since
in order to calculate something as
ridiculous as how drunk a fictional
character is we're forced to explore the
history of global trade and the
evolution of cork based technology I
love my job anyway what does any of this
mean for our Theory well it tells us
that royalty like Tyrion Lannister would
likely be drinking wines that are aged
or fortified ie the really strong stuff
in the 16th century fortifying wine
became so popular and so strong it would
make a box of Franzia look like an
oversized juice box the most popular
fortified wines of the day like Molesey
sherry and port all have alcohol
contents of around 22% alcohol by volume
that number on its own might not mean a
lot to you but by comparison an average
bottle of wine nowadays is gonna be in
the realm of eleven percent alcohol by
volume so the stuff that we see Tyrion
drinking throughout Game of Thrones is
gonna be nearly twice as strong and
honestly he can go up from there in a
Clash of Kings the second novel of the
series Tyrion reveals that when Robert
Baratheon was killed by a boar he'd been
consuming fortified wine that was three
as strong as usual which would seem to
indicate that it's alcohol by volume was
around 40% which is as strong as a hard
liquor like whiskey but he's downing it
like wine so for our purposes today
we're safe to assume that Tyrion is
drinking strong fortified wine at about
20% alcohol by volume but of course
knowing what Tyrion is drinking is only
part of the equation to determine how
drunk he's really getting we need to
consider how much he's drinking and how
quickly he's drinking it our best
scenario for this is Tyrion and Santa's
wedding banquet from season 3 now
obviously we don't see the whole scene
but we can figure it out and make some
estimates based on what we do see 4:1
Tyrion is filling his chalice to the
very top which is the bad sign a serving
of wine is typically about 4 to 5 fluid
ounces but the full volume of this glass
is gonna be something similar to this
modern Goblet from Williams and Sonoma
for 80 bucks jeez no wonder history
invented the Red Solo Cup Lannisters
always pay their debts yeah Lannisters
always pay Williams and Sonoma man home
goods are way too expensive anyway that
overpriced vessel for holding fluid has
a capacity of 10 ounces so each time
Tyrion fills and empties his glass he's
draining a double serving of wine in the
brief moments of the banquet that we do
see Tyrion downs two of those glasses in
a matter of minutes and more importantly
he was already drunk to begin with
Tyrion was out pre-gaming this is the
first shot that we see of him at the
reception if that face doesn't say I'm
about to regret my life choices I don't
know what does now we can't say for sure
how long that wedding reception lasts
but we can't calculate both the
conservative estimate and an aggressive
estimate assuming that the banquet is
fairly short say an hour or two and
Tyrion finishes his wine every half hour
and he's gonna consume roughly 30 to 40
fluid ounces of wine or about 1/3 of a
gallon 1.26 the liters of alcohol if
he's drinking at the breakneck pace he
seems to be polishing off a glass every
15 minutes for upwards of three hours
then maybe he drinks as much as a
hundred ounces just under three quarters
of a gallon or for those on the metric
system just shy of three liter
that is a ton of alcohol that's more
than the amount of diet coke that I
drink every day and whether you're
talking about the conservative estimate
or the aggressive estimate either way it
ain't gonna be pretty but before we
address that and determine the medical
consequences of Tyrians beverage of
choice there's one last factor that we
have to take into account Tyrians wait
alcohol tends to affect people
proportionately based on their size
so while Tyrion might be able to drink
as much as the mountain his
blood-alcohol concentration is gonna be
a lot higher than that of someone who
weighs 400 pounds Peter Dinklage the
actor who plays Tyrion Lannister stands
at four feet five inches tall and is
estimated to weigh anywhere between 88
and 112 pounds and honestly with as much
fizzy lifting drink that Tyrion is
pumping into his body a few pounds in
either direction is it gonna make that
much of a difference so let's call him a
hundred pounds or thirty five point
three five kilograms so knowing that
let's go back to our conservative number
if a man of Tyrion size drinks roughly
six glasses of strong 405 wine in the
space of about two hours that person's
peak blood-alcohol concentration is
going to be somewhere between a rum roll
please
point three zero and point three five
percents well damn I kind of expected
that to be a more climactic moments but
I guess it's really hard to get hyped
when every number that you're possibly
gonna be talking about is gonna be less
than one because let me impress this
upon you dear viewer point three and
point three five are huge numbers when
it comes to blood alcohol concentration
let me try to explain to you how scary
these numbers are even if the numbers
themselves don't seem all that scary
well first take into account that blood
alcohol concentration measures how many
grams of alcohol are in every hundred
milliliters of your blood so having
point three grams of alcohol and every
hundred milliliters of your blood is a
lot of alcohol relative the amount of
blood that you have pumping through your
veins
I mean any of you watching who passed
driver's ed should know that the legal
limit to drive in the US is point zero
eight percent which surprisingly is one
of the highest limits of any country
most others are hanging into point zero
five range and that means that Tyrion is
at least four times as drunk as someone
who would be considered a drunk driver
in the US and this scene in fact I'm
kind of limited by how much I can
impress upon you how crazy these numbers
are if you really want to see the world
through Tyrians eyes at that level of
intoxication there's actually a link in
the description to a website that I
helped work on in partnership with the
National Highway Traffic Safety
Administration that simulates going
through a night getting progressively
more impaired it's actually really cool
and gives you a better perspective at
what these numbers translate to I'll be
talking more about that at the end of
the video but for now remember that this
point three BAC is a conservative
estimate and it's already a huge number
and already that alone comes with some
intense health risks impaired breathing
impaired heart rate lapses and
consciousness even a low possibility of
death and honestly the evidence from the
show supports our calculation after the
wedding banquet when Tyrion and Sansa go
off to their bedchamber Tyrion refuses
to consummate the marriage if Sansa
doesn't want to he then takes one last
wiggle wine and passes out cold that
instance of sudden onset unconsciousness
which is played largely to lighten up a
very heavy scene is actually something
that occurs when BAC levels reach about
point three zero if now we switch over
to our aggressive estimate and say that
Tyrion had been drinking more than
at a rate closer to what we see in the
scenes that the show does put on screen
than Tyrians blood-alcohol concentration
skyrockets to a whopping point eight
four again the number on its own might
not seem impressive but think about this
that number shouldn't physically be
possible for most people a blood-alcohol
concentration of 0.45 leads to shutdown
of automatic bodily functions you know
the little things like breathing and
getting your heart to beat on its own
Tyrians BAC at his wedding is nearly
double that and that's just one instance
Como and Tyrion emerges from the crate
varies with smuggling him in at the
beginning of season five he starts
chugging wine then gives the old Boonton
rally
Barry says that he'd been drinking the
entire time on the ship so who knows how
drunk Tyrion is at this point the bottom
line is that drinking the way Tyrion
does is extraordinarily dangerous
especially for someone of his size the
numbers don't lie based on the volume of
wine he's guzzling and the speed with
which he drinks that Tyrion should have
been the first character to die in
season 1 but wait saying those slightly
inebriated viewers watching this during
their weekend a frat party here Ian's
been drinking this heavily for this long
would that mean that he's got like
really good tolerance would that mean
that he could survive drinking much more
than a normal person and honestly that's
a really good question it's actually one
I had myself as I worked on the script
but believe it or not that's not how
tolerance works alcohol tolerance is
definitely a thing but it has much more
to do with how inebriation affects
someone externally rather than
internally someone with a lot of
experience drinking might be able to
stay balanced to not slur their speech
with higher ba C's but on the inside
they'll be just as drunk as the novice
drinker who's had the same amount
alcohol tolerance doesn't affect your
blood alcohol concentration and that's
the toxicity that causes those pesky
problems like cardiac arrest breathing
issues and early death are there
anecdotal instances of people with
extraordinarily high blood alcohol
concentrations living sure there was
this one guy who stole a vehicle full of
sheep in South Africa and was recorded
with an unimaginable BAC of 1.6
percent not 0.16 percent 1.6 percent aka
20 times the legal driving limit that
person had to have been a genetic
anomaly I'm sure professor X is reaching
out to the guy as we speak but even
general tolerance doesn't determine your
BAC it just determines how long you can
stay conscious enough to get your BAC
even higher but surely with how smart
and high-functioning Tyrion always seems
to be in crucial moments of the show we
can at least say that he holds his
liquor better than anyone else let's
give that to the man at least right of
course of course well not so fast
Tyrion actually isn't the most
impressive drinker in the Game of
Thrones universe in fact he's not even
the best drinker in his family that
title belongs to the queen of meat
herself Cersei Lannister why well
consider the season 2 episode about the
Battle of Blackwater while Tyrion is
leading the defense of King's Landing
Cersei is hiding away in the hold fast
getting Dean Martin levels of drunk
liquid did with Tyrion we can perform
similar calculations on this episode
with similar assumptions but with one
big change
Cersei is a woman Cersei is actually
gonna have a higher blood alcohol
concentration than Tyrion if they both
drink the same amount why well generally
speaking women have a higher proportion
of their body weight as fast
sorry no shame it's just a fact and fat
has a very low water content compared to
muscle the water and muscle tissue helps
dilute alcohol in the bloodstream more
thereby creating a lower blood alcohol
concentration so when we account for all
of Circe's drinking the time elapsed her
gender her weight all that good stuff we
get a peak blood-alcohol concentration
of 0.63 sure it's not quite as high as
the highest possible calculation that we
got for Tyrion but there are two things
to consider here one this is still a BAC
that would kill most people and two
compared to Tyrion and Cersei handles
this level of drunkenness like a champ
when Tyrion gets this drunk he wipes his
mouth on a tablecloth and passes out in
front of his bride when Cersei gets this
drunk she tries to comfort her son and
tell him stories while the city around
her collapses
I mean sure she says some really awful
things to Sansa in these scenes but
Cersei says terrible things when she's
sober so I don't think that really
counts every breath you drew in my
presence
noise so tyrion might get the award for
drunkest in the family but the overall
best drinker is undeniably Cersei damnit
just another crown that she ripped off
of someone's head but hey that's just a
theory a film theory and wait right
there because I want to talk about this
really cool website that I worked on so
full disclosure this is an episode I've
had kicking around on my to-do list for
a while now and then Nitsa the National
Highway Traffic Safety Administration
came a-knockin wanting to partner with
film theory and it was like the fates
gonna lie that seems awfully random you
say skeptically why would they want a
partner with film theory well one
because we're super cool dumb but two
because we specialize in translating
complicated educational concepts into
fun videos that most people can
understand like this one and blood
alcohol concentration they actually
asked me to serve as a guide through
this really cool 360-degree website that
gives you a first-person experience of a
night on the town getting more and more
buns maybe you can't get up to Tyrion
coma levels of drunkenness like
point-eight so you can get your BAC to
some dangerously large numbers and like
I said the episode because so much of
blood alcohol concentration depends on
perceptual differences that you
experience the different levels this is
a great way to experience it firsthand
and the safety of your own home and for
free you're not actually imma pay for
any alcohol even go and tell me how it
goes in fact you'll see me there as I
guide you through the experience go up
against my raging nerd brain and bar
trivia just listen to my snarky remarks
as I wait there for you to choose a
darned ring seriously just just pick the
darn thing all in all it was a fantastic
project to work on and it presents a
super fun way to learn about the effects
of alcohol a 360 degree choose your own
adventure style evening of getting drunk
it's not too shabby so go to the website
you see on screen or just hammer the
link in the top line of the description
to go and check it out not just I will
thank you but your future self will
thank you too and in fact the future has
taught me anything when that meeting
eventually happens you will have cause
behind paradox but it will be so worth
it so one last time check out this
website or click the link on the top of
the description to have some drinks
attempt and fail at darts and try to
seduce people while getting sloppy at
the counter oh well watched over by your
little guardian angel matpat don't worry
guys I got you covered now if you'll
excuse me next week call me Pippen cuz
I've got some magic too